- This episode of StarTalk
is brought to you by CuriosityStream.
Hey YouTubeverse, up next,
Adam Savage talks about building stuff.
(upbeat music)
This is StarTalk.
I'm your host, Neil deGrasse Tyson,
your personal astrophysicist,
and we're coming to you from my office
at the Hayden Planetarium
of the American Museum of Natural History
right here in New York City.
Cohost today, Chuck Nice.
Chuck?
- Hey Neil, always good to
be here at the cosmic crib.
- [Neil] And who we making
a sandwich with here?
- Ah.
- We've seen him before!
- Yes we have, we did--
- [Neil] The one, the
only, the inimitable.
(Chuck imitates fanfare)
Adam Savage!
- Yes!
- Adam, welcome back!
- Thank you very much!
- [Neil] It's like your
third time on StarTalk.
- It's been too long since
I've been in this office.
- It has been too long.
We enjoyed your last
visit, and I feel like
we're lifelong friends,
even though we've only had
a few times together.
- It feels like culturally we're--
- Culturally, that's what it is.
- We like bounce a lot--
- Natural overlap--
- The cultural Venn
diagram has quite the area
where you two overlap.
- And that creates the friendship
even without individual time together.
- I see what you're doing and I think,
oh, that's awesome!
(laughter)
- Cool man.
- [Neil] So we've got you on.
Actually you have a new book?
- I do, holy cow--
- I'll talk about your book.
I'll do the talking about your book.
- Okay, all right.
- Okay?
- Okay.
- Because it looks better.
Doesn't it, Chuck?
- That is, that's called public relations.
(laughter)
When he talks about his
book, it's bragging.
- It's bragging!
- When you talk about it,
it's public relations.
- There you go.
- But enough about me, what
did you think of my book?
(laughs)
- So "Every Tool is a Hammer."
Great title, and this, you know,
my favorite picture in here
is they have a lot of interesting pictures
like you in your workshop.
My favorite is the stuff that you dumped
out of your backpack.
- Oh.
- But they're neatly organized
which is cool!
Like seeing what's in it,
and I like John Hodgman's comment.
He said, "This is a map of his brain."
- Nice.
- I thought that was
a very good comment.
- And I feel like venturing
into that unknown territory--
- Yeah, for some people
you don't wanna go there.
But for Adam Savage, yeah, you wanna see
what's been driving him his whole life.
- That is so funny.
Some people, you don't wanna go there.
My wife left her, she
journals, and it was out--
- She journals?
- She journals.
- And so the journal was on the bed--
- [Neil] No, you did not!
- No, I'm laying on the
bed and watching TV.
The journal was sitting right there.
She comes in the room and she goes,
"Oh my god, I left my journal."
But she goes, "You
didn't read it, did you?"
And I went, "I don't wanna
know what's going on up there!"
(laughter)
I don't want any parts of what
is happening in your head.
- Well, if your wife said,
"I hope you didn't read my journal,"
that does not bode well.
- What movie in existence
in which someone read
someone else's journal and
it all turned out great?
(laughs)
- Good point!
- That's so funny.
- There ain't no movie about that.
- My twin boys used to
like sit in their bunk beds
and talk every night, and my mom was like,
"What are they talking about?"
I'm like, "I don't know,
that's their private moment.
"I'm not gonna listen in."
- Yeah, I don't wanna know,
let them have their moment.
- But I wanna know what's on in his head,
and so does our fan base.
- Now that is so true because
I have their questions.
- This is a Cosmic Queries
edition of StarTalk,
and we just solicited
our fan base questions,
know when they'd land in
the lap of Adam Savage
about just making stuff.
- Yeah.
- And so, Chuck, I haven't seen them.
Chuck reviewed them just this morning.
- I'm actually reviewing them, and--
- Adam hasn't seen them so
let's see what you've got.
- Yeah, and these are cool.
And as usual, we always start
with a Patreon patron because
they support us--
- Because we're that low.
- Well, no!
- We're that high.
- We're that high, that
we have supporters.
- I wanna be a member
Patreon so that I could get
my questions answered by somebody.
- Believe it or not, you can.
You can actually donate to Patreon
and then ask yourself a question.
- That's how I get on that list?
- Exactly.
- That's what I will do.
I will ask myself. (laughs)
- That would be funny.
- All right, I'll do that.
- All right, here we go.
This is Bike and Birds says,
"Hey, Adam, we've all heard of examples
"of items or procedures
getting discovered by accident.
"Microwaves, penicillin,
even chocolate chip cookies.
"Through all of your
different experiments,
"was there an outcome or
product that was produced
"that was applied to another test
"or maybe even applications
outside of the show?"
And this is--
- Is that kind of like, did he
invent anything by accident?
- [Chuck] Did you ever
- It was a long way, it was
a long walk around the block.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Off the off ramp,
he took the cloverleaf to get back on.
- I have a comment and a question
but an autobiographical story first.
(chuckles)
Actually--
- By the way, there's a
word for that in science.
It's serendipity.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- A great word.
There was a moment.
I can't think of anything
we invented by accident,
but I do remember we were on--
- Up on Discovery.
- We were on Hawaii
on MythBusters shooting
"Duct Tape Island,"
and this was the conceit
Jamie and I get stranded on--
- Jaimie your co-host from MythBusters.
- So Jamie Hyneman and I get
stranded on a deserted island
and all we have is a palette
of several hundred rolls of duct tape.
What do we do?
(laughter)
- Wait, wait, wait.
So is MacGyver tuning in to this episode?
More things to do with duct tape.
- Exactly, so we made shelter,
we actually made traps
and caught chickens.
We ended up making a 21-foot
long outrigger canoe,
with which we were able
to get past the breakwater
of the North Shore of Oahu.
But there was a moment
when Jamie was asked
to make a still for
distilling clean water.
Sorry, fresh water from the salt water.
And so he was digging into
the beach to make a hole,
and the procedure is
you dig into the beach,
you make a hole.
It's gonna be kind of a damp hole
because it's on the
beach, and you let sit in
some plastic with a rock in the middle.
And as water condenses from,
the salt water collects on the inside
of the membrane you've put,
you can catch it in a cup
and drink fresh water.
However, Jamie noticed that when he dug in
and tasted just the water
that was being filtered
through the sand, that it was
much less brackish and salty.
And so he got really
excited about the idea
that the sand of the beach
itself was filtering the water.
- Interesting.
- And we explained that
this was a whole episode
about duct tape.
And while this was really interesting,
it really didn't fit within our narrative.
But he kept insisting and
so we ended up shooting
this whole sequence with Jamie,
which I think we put on the web
because that was the most interesting part
of that day for him, was
the idea that the sand
filtered the salt out.
But this was a classic
thing of Jamie going,
"This is the thing I'm interested in,"
and we're saying, "No, that's not what
"the episode is about."
He's like, "I don't
care what you're saying,
"I just wanna talk about this thing."
- And now I love all my water gritty.
(laughs)
- Yes, just a little bit--
- I need just a little bit
of grit in all of my water.
- I'll drink it out of my boot, thank you.
- Cool.
- All right, cool.
Next question.
- That's a great story.
Great story, great story.
This is John Cole from Facebook who says,
"Between StarTalk and the
Tested YouTube channel,
"I am in heaven!
"Hello, Adam.
"How do you get over
the maker's equivalent
"of writer's block?"
- Oh, good one!
- What a great question!
- Good one.
- John Cole, you are thinking, my friend.
- [Neil] So do you ever just
walk in your garage and say,
"I don't know what I'm
gonna put together today."
- Totally.
But more than that, I also
hit moments where I spend
a whole day assembling
something and realized
that I have assembled
it chirally backwards
and that I have to take the whole--
(overlapping dialogue)
- Explain what chirally means.
- Well, chirally is left and right.
Your hands are chiral because--
- Let Chuck explain.
- I'm so sorry.
Chuck, what is chiral?
- It's the mirror image
without the mirror.
- Nice!
- Ooh, that was much more concise.
- That was way better than
where you were going with that.
- Yeah, it was.
I was being way too wordy.
- You can make something that
is the mirror image of itself
and then you hold them together
and they're mirror images.
- Exactly.
- And our amino acids have one chirality,
and they all have the same
chirality for all life on Earth.
And when we found amino
acids in asteroids,
we found that they were
50/50 of both chiralities.
So we knew that it didn't care
and there wasn't one life form,
because amino acids aren't alive yet,
that over ran the other.
So our chirality is the one
chirality in the whole world.
And there's suspicions that
if there was another life form
with the other chirality,
of our molecules,
that you wouldn't be
able to metabolize them
if you ate them because the
molecules wouldn't fit together.
(overlapping dialogue)
Might not even be able to taste it.
- Oh that's cool.
- And they would probably be like a guy,
one half of his face will be black
and the other half of
his face would be white.
- It's really angry and sweet.
- Right, exactly.
- So from a standpoint of making,
whenever you have two
parts that are chiral,
it can be a devilishly
difficult assembly problem
because everything looks very similar
but the order of
operations is very precise.
- Tetris is kind of like that,
two of the pieces are
mirror opposite each other.
- Right.
So regularly in making,
you hit a spot where you--
- [Neil] I'm sorry, 3D
Tetris I was thinking, sorry.
(chuckles)
- So you hit a spot where
you've screwed something up
and you feel, I feel
really dejected about it
and I don't feel like moving forward
or I don't feel like
undoing the five hours
of work I've just done and I'm angry,
I'm pissed off, I feel sad about it.
- That's funny because I feel the same way
whenever I put anything
together from IKEA.
(laughs)
- Chuck, the table is upside down.
- Really?
- Yes, totally!
IKEA is absolutely ripe for
that kind of screwing up.
- But go ahead.
- And how does everything
fit in a flat box anyway?
Isn't there something
that should not be able
to fit in a flat box?
- The IKEA car would go boop.
- All right, sorry.
- Go ahead.
- There's a line from a Mary
Karr who wrote "Liars' Club",
wrote about what she
does with writer's block.
And she says, "If I can't
think about what to write,
"I sit at my desk and I copy writers
"I love in longhand because
my fidelity at the desk
"is to be writing, whether
it's my own writing or not."
- What an exercise!
- It's a beautiful
exercise and I take that
to heart in the shop.
If I can't think of what to make,
I organize something in my shop.
A drawer, a shelf, a bin.
I take something and I adjust it because--
- So you do shop time no matter what.
- I do shop time and I
do so much more shop time
than I ever did before because I realized
it's a deep part of that whole process,
of prepping the shop and
prepping myself for the work.
- I do a little bit something like that.
I have a book called "The
Greatest Wits of All Time"
and they're phrases out of
letters and correspondence
from people that have extraordinary wit.
And I just read it.
I say, wow, that was an
awesome juxtaposition
of words and phrases or rhythm,
and that just sort of
rebaptizes me into a mood
that I then say, okay, I'm ready--
- [Adam] That feels fertile.
- There you go, I like that.
- So do you ever suffer
writer's block, Neil?
- No, no, I go through this exercise.
I have a lot of books written by writers
who like writing about writing,
also about whatever else they wrote about.
Did that sentence make any--
(laughs)
- It sounds very meta.
- There's a lot of inception today.
- I would never wanna write that sentence.
That's only a speakable sentence.
And there's one sentence that,
I think I uttered this
in our last recording,
a sentence from "The Great Gatsby."
This is a sentence where I
knew I still have not become
a great writer, and maybe never will.
- [Chuck] Oh wow, okay.
I have to hear this now.
- "In his blue gardens men and girls
"came and went like moths
"amid the whispers, the
champagne and the stars."
- That's a great--
- I read that, that's why I
am not a novelist and he is.
- You reminded me of one
my favorite passages from--
- Obviously this was from the
Great Gatsby's, his party.
- Yeah.
- You reminded me of a line from Chandler.
- That's like a perfect simile.
- Plus, he mentioned--
- Came and went as moths.
- Yes, as moths.
- That's beautiful.
It's very elegant.
- Amid the whispers of
the champagne and the stars.
- Incredible.
- You know, I didn't come
here to feel inadequate.
(laughs)
- And yet.
- And yet here we are.
- So what were you saying, Adam?
- I'm saying it reminds me
of this line from Chandler
where his hero, Marlowe, is
sitting in a waiting room
for too long and he describes
the time passing as,
"the minutes tiptoed by
their fingers to their lips."
- Lovely.
- Ooh yeah.
- Okay, so I have one.
It's a quote from my father.
"Seriously, what the hell
are you still doing here?"
(laughter)
- You haven't moved out
of the basement yet?
- That's a talk every father has.
- All right.
- I'll just remind people,
we got Adam here because
he's got a new book.
We would have him anyway
even without the book,
let's make that clear.
- I appreciate that.
- Okay, but he was made available to us
by Simon & Schuster, okay?
For free, right?
He was like in New York doing media,
and I guess we count as media.
- You do!
- We do, yeah.
Nice.
- I can handle that.
- "Every Tool is a Hammer:
Life is What You Make It."
I see what he did there.
- Yeah, that's very cool.
- Right, right.
So, Adam--
- "Every Tool is a Hammer"
actually does sound like something
Donald Trump would say though.
I'm just saying.
(laughter)
- No, the phrase of mine he's grabbed is,
"I reject your reality
and substitute my own."
(laughter)
- Very nice.
- Is that a quote from you?
- That is.
- He actually quoted that?
- No, he hasn't quoted that but--
(overlapping dialogue)
- I love it.
All right, let's take Mitch
Morris who comes to us--
- You're doing well with the names today.
- That's because they're regular names!
- Yeah, regular.
How racist can you get?
- I can get a lot more racist.
I'm just letting you
know, since we're asking.
(laughter)
- All right, go on.
- But you are right, it's
extremely, what do you call it,
presumptive of me.
- Yes, yes.
- All right, here we go.
Mitch Morris from Instagram.
(laughter)
Mitch Morris from Instagram
wants to know this.
What is the most important
tool ever invented?
That's for the both of you.
What an interesting little question.
Very simple little question
but very interesting.
I'll answer first because I want him
to bring closure to the question.
So when I was younger, I said, wow,
this crescent wrench is
really useful, right?
Because you can adjust it.
And then I discovered the--
- Miter saw?
- No, no, no, the--
- Vise grip.
- The vise grip!
- Oh!
- Oh.
- And I said, oh, I've died
and gone to heaven, vise grip.
And then, and then--
- [Chuck] You got better than vise grip?
- Yes!
- Okay.
- The most important tool is money
to pay somebody else to fix it!
(laughter)
That became the most important tool.
I ain't fixing this plumbing.
I'm gonna go hire a plumber.
That's gonna be my tool kit for--
- Wow, capital!
(laughter)
You may have just answered the question.
- I have to say in the
circles I travel in,
a crescent wrench is known
as a nut corner rounder,
and the vise grips are
known as the professional
nut corner rounder.
They can mess up, don't get me wrong,
I love both of those tools.
- Corner rounder (mumbles) your hex
and removing the edges to it--
- Yeah, until they can no longer be--
- Right, a nut corner rounder.
- A nut corner rounder.
- You're right.
- I have to go to the simplest,
I mean one of the simple
machines, the lever.
I feel like the ability
to move heavy objects
with a mechanical advantage,
and the lever exists before the
wheel or any rollers to me--
- It's Archimedes who said...
- "Give me a lever and a place to stand
"and I can move the world."
- I don't think he said lever.
He just said, "Give me a place to stand."
- Give me a place,
or I think he was describing the--
- Yes of course, but I'm
saying that was implicit.
- Okay!
- Give me a lever and a place.
Just give me a place to stand
and I can move the world.
Beautiful.
- There you go.
- Yeah, yeah, next question.
Right, good stuff so far.
- Okay, lever, I'll give you a lever.
We do the lever.
Next question.
- Here's the next question
from (mumbles) Wumoshop.
Wumoshop, yes.
(laughter)
- Sounds problematic.
- Do you have a brain injury
that's presenting with words?
- I think I just had a stroke.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Wumoshop.
"Hi Neil, I'm Adam.
"You guys are both my heroes.
"Which would you say would
be the more important
"for the future of invention?
"Good old fashioned mechanical know how
"or advancements in material science,
"i.e., inventing a new
type of suspension bridge
"that is stronger and lighter
"versus discovering a stronger
and lighter titanium alloy?"
- Ooh, okay, we don't
have time to answer that.
- Oh! (laughter)
- Where do you go, Wumoshop?
- We got to take a break.
More when we come back
of the Maker's Edition
os Cosmic Queries.
- [Presenter] This
episode is brought to you
by CuriosityStream, a
subscription streaming service
made for viewers with inquiring minds,
including StarTalk fans just like you.
Get access starting at $2.99 a month.
Let me tell you about CuriosityStream's
How to Build series.
If you're a person that's a maker
and you wanna step up your garage game,
well, this is the show for you.
It gives you unprecedented access
to some of the world's
most advanced engineers
who are responsible for
satellites, supercars,
and the wings of jumbo jets.
Their Satellites episode is really cool.
They talk about how to build a machine
that will live for over a decade in space.
And of course, how it will deal
with the harshness of
the environment of space
and the suspense about
getting it into orbit.
Go to CuriosityStream.com/StarTalk
for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
and nonfiction series.
And for our listeners, enter
the promo code STARTALK
when you're prompted
during the signup process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days.
And now, back to Adam Savage on StarTalk.
- We're back, StarTalk.
Adam Savage, the one and
only of MythBusters fame.
And he's running on his own, making stuff.
He's got a new book out called,
"Every Tool is a Hammer:
Life is What You Make It."
You see what he did there, Chuck?
- Very nice.
- He did that.
I got Chuck Nice with me
and we're doing Cosmic Queries.
- Yes we are.
And before we went to
break, we had a question
from Wumoshop who says,
"Hi Neil, I'm Adam.
"You guys are both my heroes.
"Which would you say would
be the more important
"for the future of invention?
"Good old fashioned mechanical know how
"or advancements in material science."
- [Neil] And go.
- Good old fashioned mechanical know how.
We are always gonna be
advancing in material science,
and there will sometimes be things
that we cannot replicate
because we lose the technology
or we forget a process.
But as long as we have a deep foundation
in mechanical knowledge, in making things
and the roots and the physics
of putting stuff together,
we can utilize those advances
and we can adjust to the changes
in the available materials as they come.
- Wow, great answer.
- I only kind of agree with that.
- Uh-oh.
- I'm agreeing 50%.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm into material science.
It is one of the most underappreciated
unheralded branches of
science in this world.
If you go back 50 years,
hardly any, now I'm not
bragging about this advance,
I'm just citing it as a
difference in our lives.
You go back 50 years, hardly
anything was made of plastic.
- [Chuck] Correct.
- And almost everything
is made of plastic today.
- And it's working out great.
- For many things,
as long as you don't have
to throw it away, okay?
It's working out great.
The plastic is stronger,
it's more reliable
than other materials and you can mold it.
And just think of the
things that having simple
"standard mechanical
knowledge" would, so what?
Look what this material can do.
There are materials now that have memory
of a shape they once had
so you can deform it--
- I sleep on it.
- Then you'd like wet it
and then it goes back
to the previous shape.
Nothing in your lab,
nothing in your garage
is ready for that.
- But within the one is
better than the other,
mechanical knowledge can push
humanity forward on its own,
whereas material science
can't necessarily.
- With the good materials,
you don't need the mechanical knowledge.
It's built into the material itself.
- I totally disagree with that.
- Smackdown!
(laughter)
Meet me in the Octagon.
Smackdown.
- So as an aside, I
just finished a new show
for the Science Channel
called Savage Builds
in which I build absurd things every week.
In the first episode, we
made a suit of Iron Man armor
in 3D printed titanium.
And speaking of material science,
I discovered that when
you 3D print Titanium,
you can attenuate it's grain structure
so that it is far stronger
than normal titanium
because you can give it these super tight
little crystallin granules.
- Get closer.
- Yeah.
- Make it tighter.
- Wait, wait, wait,
except that makes it
denser it seems to me.
- It didn't in this case.
No, it's still 45% the
weight of steel and--
- Interesting, okay, okay--
- As stronger and stronger.
- If you made it denser, you would lose
some of the value of it being light?
- Yeah, no.
This stuff was amazing.
We had potato chip-thin pieces.
They were bullet proof.
- What?
- Bullets slid right off of this.
- Now wait a minute,
is this something that
was already discovered
or is it just something
that you discovered.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, GE is using 3D printed titanium
in their jet engines right now.
- Okay.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, what if he
accidentally discovered--
(overlapping dialogue)
- It's a property that
you found for yourself.
- I was working with--
(overlapping dialogue)
There's an amazing engineering school
called the Colorado School of Minds.
- Yes, everyone knows that, yes.
- Those guys are incredible,
and I worked directly with them
in their Additive
Manufacturing Department.
- Okay, so he just figured out
a brilliant new material
to make armor for knights.
(laughter)
600 years late.
- Exactly, man.
- That's great.
- Yeah, but I can't wait
to see what new material
is coming down the pipe and how that might
transform how we live.
I think about that all the time.
- Okay, all right.
Excellent question once again
from our listening audience.
- And just for the point of (mumbles)
we transitioned from ooh, that's cheap,
it's made of plastic; to oh,
this is made of plastic, fine.
I don't have any problems.
It'll last forever.
That happened, we're about
the same age probably.
That happened in our lifetime.
- It did, it did.
- Yes, okay, just--
- I totally agree.
- I don't wanna smack you down too hard.
Just the Octagon will decide this.
(laughter)
Okay, does anyone know the Octagon?
- I'm sure they do.
And there's a lot of UFC
fans listening right now.
(laughter)
- I don't know what the
Venn diagram is of...
- Right now, there's a guy calculating
an equation of kick ass.
All right now, this is Mike Pumaking.
- Pumaking?
- Pumaking.
- Pump making?
- Pump making.
I don't know.
These people, I think they're
just screwing with me.
- You think so?
(laughter)
- I really do.
They're like, is it Chuck?
We're gonna just make up names.
All right, here we go.
Mr. Savage, what is something
that you would think
would be possible to build in the future
that is the now considered
science fiction?
- [Neil] Ooh, very good.
- That's a great question.
- Room temperature superconduction.
- Wow!
Well, you went for a big one!
- I did!
I'm really excited about,
speaking of material science,
I'm really excited about graphene and--
- See, he came back to
me, material science.
- All right, so that's your answer?
- That's my answer, room
temperature superconduction
is gonna be, I believe it
will happen in our lifetime.
- And once that happens,
will we actually be able
to have space ships that stop and hover?
- I don't know.
Actually, one of the things we'll learn
a significant amount about is our brains,
the processing power of our brains.
I feel like as computers
become more powerful,
they're going to become
a real interesting window
into consciousness and sentience
and what it is to think about the thinker.
- Nice.
- You know, I hadn't quite
heard it put that way,
but now that I have, I agree 100%
because it's hard for the
brain to study itself.
But if we make computers
that are becoming better,
better approximations
of our brain, now we have
something we can study.
And so we would asymptotically
come to an understanding
of our brain simply by
making our computers
that much more complex,
possibly one day achieving
consciousness themselves
and becoming our overlords.
- There you go.
- I think if we ever
made a machine conscious,
the first thing it's gonna say to us is
"What the fuck did you do?"
- That's so true.
- All right, next question.
- All right, cool.
Good, good, good question.
- Cosmic Queries version of StarTalk.
- Now here's somebody,
he calls himself or herself
The Dragon Horde of Dice.
- Dragon Horde of Dice.
- Okay, there you go.
- That person's mama probably did not give
that person that name.
- No, but I think her name is Kate
because it says @KateNater.
- [Neil] Okay.
(laughter)
- So there you go.
- "Hey, Adam.
"Since I know you do cosplay,
"what is the most complex
mechanical prop costume
"you've ever tried to build?
"Like a prop or costume
that had no moving parts
"or could collapse/expand,
"or something that you may
have tried to just recreate."
- Did you make Transformers proud ever?
- Oh gosh, no!
I have not done a Transformers costume.
A few years ago, I've been
obsessed with armor since 1981
when I went and saw Excalibur with my dad.
- I love Excalibur.
- John Boorman's film--
- My top five favorite films.
- Amazing film.
- And then I learned disturbingly--
- Yeah, I know the fact
you're about to tell me.
Go ahead.
- Oh really?
No, no, no maybe not.
- I don't know the fact, please.
- Excuse me, I'm having
a private conversation
with my man here?
(laughter)
Okay, so Excalibur from the
early 1980s, John Boorman,
an early film that had
Patrick Stewart in it.
- Patrick Stewart, Liam Neeson.
- [Neil] Liam Neeson was in it.
- Gabriel Byrne.
- And so is Helen Mirren?
- Oh, so beautiful in that movie.
- It's the King Arthur story told.
- Thank you.
- Much later I realized,
I think half the reason
why I liked the movie
was because of the soundtrack.
- Oh, okay.
- A very powerful Wagnerian,
and that which is not Wagnerian
comes from Carmina Burana.
Very emotional energetic music
that you just feel in every scene.
And I thought to myself,
maybe the movie's not so good
but the music was amazing
and I completely compensated for it.
- I watched it recently.
It's still super campy and
still really impressively great.
- But did you watch it on mute?
- No.
(laughter)
- With subtitles and mute.
Try that next time.
- I did not apply a control, Chuck.
- Okay, so your answer.
- Oh, so I've been obsessed
with armor since then
and I actually, when I was a
junior in high school in 1984,
I built a suit of armor
out of roofing aluminum
with my dad and wore it
to school on Halloween
and passed out of heat
exhaustion in the third period.
It's all just up north at
Sleepy Hollow High School.
- Hence your Twitter handle, donttrythis.
- Exactly.
- At home.
- A few years ago, I
called up Terry English
who's the master armorer that built
all the armor for Excalibur.
He lives in the southern
tip of England in Cornwall.
And I went to his studio
a couple summers ago
and spent 10 days embedded
with him as his assistant
while he and I manufactured me a suit
of King Arthur's armor from Excalibur.
- [Neil] You were an apprentice!
- I was an apprentice, and he made me
my lifetime goal suit of armor
of Arthur's armor from Excalibur.
- Wow, pretty intense.
- It was so intense.
It was amazing.
He lives in this incredible
sort of overgrown shop in Cornwall.
- So he's you in England.
- Yeah, totally.
(laughter)
- Woah, there's only room
for one per continent,
I think, I don't know.
- That was by far my favorite
mechanical prop construction.
- Okay, but it was not
electronic or anything,
it was just mechanical.
- No, no, it's hammering
aluminum all day long.
- Did you have chainmail and everything?
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
- Wow, that's a pretty wild, man.
Congratulations on that.
- You still have it?
- Oh yeah, yeah, I wear
it every chance I get.
- How'd you get it through TSA?
- Actually, when I--
- Whatever they were known back then.
- No, I actually took it
to New Zealand last year
to make a little film with
Peter Jackson about it
where a demon tears my arm off.
We called it, "A Farewell to Arms."
(laughter)
- Things are getting
weird real quickly here.
- When I carried the armor with me,
I was thinking this is priceless to me.
I can't really insure this.
So I checked it as luggage
with a GPS transceiver
in my luggage so I could monitor it
being loaded on to my plane.
- That's pretty wild.
- I felt if the airline was gonna tell me
they couldn't find it, I wanted to know
that I could find it.
- I got to tell you something.
- Plane goes down, they
can't find the black box
but he found the--
- He found the suit of armor.
- We found the suit of armor.
- I don't know where anybody else is--
- We have no idea why all
these people are dead,
but we do have an awesome
suit of armor right now.
(laughter)
- Oh my God.
Wow man, that's pretty wild.
- You're far weirder than I ever--
- But wait a minute--
- I extrapolated for you.
- Wait, you and Peter Jackson
are making home movies?
- Occasionally, yeah.
- What's going on?
- And for those who didn't know,
the Lord of the Ring series
was mostly filmed in New Zealand.
- By Peter Jackson,
and Peter Jackson was inspired to,
one of the key inspirations for him
in making Lord of The Rings was Excalibur.
- So I'm not the only
one who likes Excalibur?
It's my top five movies.
- No, dude, it's a super important film.
- But other four, really weird not that,
but that's in there.
- That's sweet.
I can't say it's one of my favorite.
I'm not cool enough.
- I need help.
- One other thing.
- Go ahead.
These five movies are
like the only five movies
I've ever not only seen
a zillion times but
sat through the director's narration.
- [Adam] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Director's commentary?
- The director's commentary.
Because you have to like the movie so much
that you don't even need to watch
this next iteration of it
and hear somebody just talk through it.
- Nice.
Well, you've also seen it that many times.
- Well, that's how you
earn the director's cut
at that point.
- Right, exactly.
All right, now I got to know
what are the other four movies.
- Yeah, no, I do too.
- Really?
- Yeah, because if that's
part of the top five,
and that means there's four other movies
that made it to director's cut--
- Number one, "The Matrix."
- Okay, I'll give you that, "Matrix."
- Number two, "All That Jazz."
- With Bob Fosse?
- Bob Fosse.
- Okay, that's a good one.
- Roy Scheider.
- We have Roy Scheider
sort of playing Bob Fosse, okay?
Three, "The Conversation."
- Oh, such a good movie!
- Oh man, now I'm lost.
- Francis Ford Coppola.
- Coppola's "The Conversation."
- "The Conversation."
Four, it's a toss up between--
- Oh wait, "The Conversation,"
that's with the man and the woman?
- Yes.
- Okay, go ahead.
(laughter)
- That movie with the man and woman.
- Okay, all right, go
ahead, go ahead, go ahead,
- "Conversation."
And then there's probably a toss up here
but the "West Side Story."
- [Chuck] Amazing, that's great.
- And then "Excalibur."
I think it's fifth out of those five.
- Look, I say there's at least
nine films in my top five.
- There are nine films in my top five.
- Top five lists actually can go quantum
and we could fit lots of--
- We get another dimension--
- You've got timelines on your--
- So those five are so unlike each other--
- And what an eclectic mix--
- It's really weird but I totally,
so I used to dance, okay?
So hence, the Bob Fosse.
- Have you done "Dancing With The Stars"?
- No that's so cliche, dude!
(overlapping dialogue)
- I suddenly want to see you on that show.
- When I was dancing, no
one was publishing my books.
(mumbles) I don't need to dance anymore.
Okay.
So what, Chuck?
(overlapping dialogue) I'm serious!
- Do you love "Strictly Ballroom"?
- I'm dancing for nobody, okay?
My people have come a long way.
(laughter)
- Copy that.
- Okay.
- Okay?
So there's that, and I wrote a column
for a magazine under
the pen name of Merlin,
so I have extra interest
in the Merlin Arthurian legends
and I have the Malory book in velum,
you know, so there's that.
"Matrix" of course is the,
"Matrix" one of course.
Not two and three.
- Absolutely perfect.
- It has to be there?
- There are two other movies?
- And "The Conversation"
which is so, so well done.
- An amazing film.
- There's no explosions,
there's no chase scenes.
It was a story well done.
And so there I am.
- Nice!
- Those are my five.
- Now listen, so there you go people,
now you know what you're doing,
Netflix and chill with Neil's list.
(laughter)
- That's a weird list.
- What a weird list to
Netflix and chill, right?
- Oh, and "West Side Story" is New York.
It's the city, it's I'm half Puerto Rican.
My mother's name is Sunchita
Maria Feliciano Tyson.
Okay, that's her name.
- "West Side Story" is such a masterpiece.
- It's a masterpiece.
- A masterpiece.
- Masterpiece! Masterpiece!
And while I don't know
how to compose music,
if I ever could, I'm
imagining that I could compose
the music that we hear
in "West Side Story".
That's where I'm thinking,
that's what I would reach for.
- That would be your North Star.
- That'd be my North Star.
He's beautiful, I love Adam.
- [Presenter] This
episode is brought to you
by CuriosityStream, a
subscription streaming service
made for viewers with inquiring minds,
including StarTalk fans just like you.
Get access starting at $2.99 a month.
Join CuriosityStream to hold you over
between new episodes of StarTalk radio.
Come on, we only put
out an hour of StarTalk
on YouTube every week,
so you've got some time to kill.
They've got some other
cool shows on topics
like science, history, nature and society.
Lots of cool people involved
in these shows as well.
Sigourney Weaver, Jane
Goodall, Sylvia Earle
and so many more.
Go to CuriosityStream.com/StarTalk
For unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
and nonfiction series.
And for our listeners, enter
the promo code STARTALK
when you're prompted
during the signup process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days.
And now, back to Adam Savage on StarTalk.
- Back for our third and final segment,
and I don't want this show to end.
- It's been a good show.
- [Neil] Maker Cosmic Queries
edition with Adam Savage
who makes stuff.
"Every Tool is a Hammer:
Life is What You Make It."
And this is, you know, it's
a window into your brain.
- Oh yeah, there's some
organized shelves--
- I like the fact that you
have photos in it, thanks.
- Oh yeah.
- Thank your publisher
for agreeing to, because
they don't always agree
to put pictures in their books.
- No they did, I threw
tons into the manuscript
and after we had the manuscript approved,
they said, "Okay, so you're responsible
"for all the permissions for the photos?"
- Oh.
(laughter)
- Publishers are such wimps
when it comes to that.
Oh man, don't get me started.
Yeah, so definitely.
So next question, what was that?
- All right, so this
was Lane from Minnesota
who said, "As a builder,
I remember failed projects
"more then the successes."
- Stop there.
So tell me about failures
relative to successes.
- Well, we talk about
this a lot these days.
Failure is a really popular word.
And Silicon Valley says, you know,
"Build fast and break things."
We talk about educating kids,
we talk about teaching them how to fail.
And I have a particular take on this
because I think failure is a fine word--
- But there's a version of
that from the '90s or '80s,
which was shocking when we first heard it,
was, "If it ain't broke, break it."
- Break it.
- Yes.
- So that way, you might
invent something better
than the thing you had before.
And just because it worked,
doesn't mean that's the best
version of what it could be.
- Indeed.
- Or you just end up with
a lot of broken shit.
(laughter)
- That's if you're creative.
- There's always broken shit behind me.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Exactly.
- All right.
- Go ahead.
- But we don't really mean failure.
Wrong turns on the path
to get to a success
are not failures, they're
simply iterations.
And I'm here--
- And that's not a euphemism or anything?
- No my--
- Smells like one.
- What I wanna preach is
that both science and art
are iterative processes that
include tons of wrong turns.
And the wrong turns aren't outliers,
they're part of that process.
And we go up the path and we're like,
okay, this isn't the path
so let's go back to the fork
and continue down another path
and see if that's the path.
And so yes, I also remember my failures
more than my successes because
that's where I learned.
The failures, the failures.
The wrong turns I took
to get to the right turns
are the places that I
learned the most about myself
and about how to build things
and about how to recover
from those moments.
- You know what they say
about rocket launch failures?
That they're not failures,
they're just experiments rich in data.
(laughter)
- Right in the movies,
there's always the guy who says
my experiment was a failure.
No scientist says that.
- No we don't actually.
If it's well designed, a negative result
is actually useful information to you.
- Indeed.
- Publishable information.
- You have to say that
when somebody else is
paying for what you did.
- Yeah, I was just reading
an article the other day
about how journals, publishing journals,
don't highlight null results.
- They don't value it in the publishing--
- [Adam] They don't value
it in the publishing--
- Yeah, yeah, and we should more.
It's a problem.
- That's true, I never thought of that.
But yeah, there is a great deal of value--
- Tells you what not to do.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Exactly, it tells the next person
look, this is what I
did, it didn't work out
and now I don't have to
waste time going down that--
- That's a scientific inquiry
that is equally as important
as some brand new fact about--
- Oh no, that makes a lot of sense.
- You know, Chuck has a new
hero of the recent months
who may have been
responsible for sending us
down the wrong path,
because his mantra was
failure is not an option.
This was from Apollo 13.
And this is Gene Kranz.
So failure is not an option.
And then that became America.
We're not gonna fail.
And then we lost track
of the value of failure.
- The most surprising
thing I learned from doing
MythBusters for 13 years
was how surprisingly creative
the scientific discipline is
and how it mirrors the
creative discipline.
To me, conducting experiments,
conducting and building
experimental methodologies
is every bit as creatively satisfying
as making a sculpture, painting a painting
or writing a book.
- I agree 100%.
- But I think it's better
when you call it a wrong turn,
the way you put it that way.
Because if you think about it,
just from a standpoint
everybody can identify--
- A driver's standpoint.
- Driver's standpoint.
When you make a wrong turn,
how many times have you done that
and discovered something
that you really liked?
- Oh, there's botanical gardens over here.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Oh my God, who knew?
- That process is the soul
of standup comedy, right?
Iterate, iterate, iterate
every joke, every joke.
- Listen, it's the same process
even when the joke works.
- Yes!
You go back and you try to crack it open
and see how can I make this even better?
(overlapping dialogue)
- If it works, break it.
- Indeed.
- Yeah, no, >
Yeah, all right, super cool.
- Next question.
- Wow, Lane.
What a great question.
You're a hero, Lane.
That's what you are.
You are.
All right, this is Chris Goes to the Park.
Thank you Chris.
(laughter)
Thanks Chris.
He said, "Hey, Adam,
are there any inventions
"your team created on MythBusters
"that you have kept or that
you might still use today?
"P.S. loved your show growing up.
It inspired me to study
engineering, now I'm an engineer.
- Ooh, ooh.
- Always amazing to hear.
There's nothing that we kept
from the public on MythBusters
except for one thing.
- Ooh.
- Kari, Grant and Tory were--
- Wait, wait, I didn't
understand the question.
You mean, is there something
you made on MythBusters
that the public never saw?
(overlapping dialogue)
- Something we came up with
or that we discovered on MythBusters
that we have somehow kept from the public.
- That's not how I read the question.
- Well, no.
He meant, but I like that.
What he meant, is there
anything that you invented
or came up that you were like wow,
this is so good I'm actually
gonna put it to use in my life.
- Right, that's how I read it.
- Wow.
Yes, I mean, really it
was the more the process
of telling the stories on MythBusters.
- But wait, that's not
as interesting a question
as the one you thought I was.
- I know, I was gonna say.
(laughter)
- Let's assume it was the
question you thought it was.
- Exactly, which is?
- Kari, Grant and Tory were
testing the explosive--
- Who, who?
Sorry, my co-hosts on MythBusters,
Keri Byron, Tory Belleci
and Grant Imahara.
They were testing a story that involved
a commonly available material
that is as close to a description
as I'm going to get, and
its explosive properties.
And what they determined
with this use case scenario
was so spectacularly
terrifyingly explosive
that we agreed to destroy the
footage of the explanation
and never tell how we got to that.
- And I thank you for that.
- Oh yeah, no.
- Bomb squads the world over
know what we've figured out on our own
and are thankful that we've decided
not to put that in the episode.
- So yeah, it's like--
- But Engineer Ben just
found it on YouTube.
- Right.
(laughter)
Did you know if you took cotton balls
and chewing gum, you
could actually bring down
the World Trade Center?
Like what?
Yeah, no, that's crazy.
- So the answer is yes, you did--
(overlapping dialogue)
- Yes, yeah.
- So you quarantined that information
and just said, to hell with it.
- The world doesn't need it.
It will not be better for
this bit of knowledge.
- Now just between us, what was the...
(laughter)
What were the materials?
- Just between you and
us, no one's listening.
- What were the materials?
(laughter)
All right, I don't wanna know to be honest
because I can't be trusted.
All right, this is Ringa Millie who says,
"How do you create new things
"that haven't before been thought of?"
In other words, what is your process
for creative discovery?
Is there any process that says,
well, you know what?
Boom.
- Well, I don't know if it's reasonable
to think about something
as, I want to make something
that's never been thought of.
I don't think we have the choice
to sequester an invention or a build
or something creative into a category
before it's been made.
And everything we made is based
on everything that we've seen.
So is it Newton that said,
"We stand on the shoulders of giants?"
- Yes.
- Just as Newton says that,
we all do, it's called--
- "If I see farther than others,
"it is because I stood on
the shoulders of giants
"who have come before me."
And that is one of the greatest
descriptions of culture
that anyone's ever penned.
That's exactly what's happening.
When I was, you know--
- Especially now.
- When I was 17,
I saw "Alien".
It took me five years to get the aesthetic
of H.R. Giger out of my system.
I had to recapitulate the aesthetics
that he was doing because
I found it so powerful,
until I kind of understood it.
That recapitulation--
- So that person is what to the movie?
- Yeah, H.R. Giger
designed the alien monster.
- You said it like
well, but, we all have--
(overlapping dialogue)
- I know, I'm sorry.
H.R. Giger is this crazy German
who designed all of the
creatures and alien technology
from the original movie "Alien",
Ridley Scott's first science fiction.
- Of course with Sigourney Weaver.
- Sigourney Weaver, Tom
Skerritt, Harry Dean Stanton.
That's one of my top five films.
An amazing film.
I mean, it's a gothic horror film,
not a science fiction movie but...
- My issue with it was that the alien
still had like a mouth, a jaw, teeth.
- Yeah, but he had a mouth in a mouth.
I mean, that's pretty creative.
- No, no, I'm just thinking
most life forms on Earth do
not have a mouth and teeth.
Like trees and worms and
butterflies and this sort of thing.
So if you're gonna have a complete alien,
you should be more
creative than even that.
Like "The Blob", 1958,
Steve McQueen movie.
- Yes.
- It's got no bones.
- Nothing.
- It's a blob.
- It's terrifying.
- What was it?
It was a blob.
- It was a blob.
- It was completely terrifying
and it would eat your
blood, suck your blood.
And you know when the blob first landed,
you know what color it was?
It was transparent.
It only turned red after
it ate its first victim.
- Woah.
- Yes!
You didn't know that!
- I did not know that.
- Oh he didn't know that!
(overlapping dialogue) I know that.
I know that!
(laughter)
And it could come through the
vents, into the (mumbles).
So to me that's creativity.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I don't think that
you can say to yourself
I wanna think of something
that's never been thought.
I think you have to just keep on thinking,
what do I want that doesn't exist?
What do I want to make extant
that I can't obtain or I can't get?
- Oh, so your urges are
guiding your creativity.
- Totally, absolutely.
And actually, that's
what this book is to me,
it's a permission slip to everyone
to follow those weird urges.
I call them secret thrills.
- So you should have titled
it Follow Your Weird Urges.
(laughter)
It'd be a bestseller overnight.
- The publisher rejected that--
(overlapping dialogue)
- Is it too late to change it?
Because that's a damn good title.
(overlapping dialogue)
Follow Your Weird Urges.
- I know what I'm signing
in your book, Neil.
- So we have to go into
lightning round now.
Okay, we have a few minutes left.
I need from you sound bite answers.
Okay, are you ready?
- Yup.
(bell rings)
- Chuck, go.
- All right, here we go.
This is Olivia Waits from Instagram.
She wants to know, how long does it take
to usually come up with a truly new idea?
- That is impossible to quantify.
(bell rings)
- Next.
- There you go.
Cana Slicker says--
- Wait, let me ask, what's the longest
and shortest time it took you
to come up with a new idea?
- Again, impossible to quantify.
- Get the range.
- The range, between
one minute and 17 hours.
- Okay (bell rings) good.
- There you go, I'll accept it.
- He pulled that one out
of his ass, the 17 hours.
(overlapping dialogue)
- Sorry, we were looking for two days.
(laughter)
- Wrong answer!
All right, go.
- Here we go.
Canasilicker.
Oh, (mumbles) I think
somebody made, nevermind.
What is your most unique out
of left field inspiration
that has ever happened to
you or even surprised you?
That is weird.
Where'd you find inspiration,
a place that you never thought you would?
- Good.
- Oh wow.
I'm gonna need time to
think about that one.
I don't have a sound
bite answer for that one.
- You have till the end of the show.
Okay, next question.
- Okay, here we go.
Julie--
- But wait,
let me reword that question.
Maybe it's the same question.
Among all your sources of inspiration,
what has been the most fertile?
- Oh, actually always reading
about the first experiment
of something that was discovered.
Reading Fizeau's speed of light
experiment is so thrilling.
- Mmm, okay, good, good.
- Wow, what a great answer
and an even better question.
- Fizeau as in Doppler-Fizeau.
It's end late 19th century, early--
- He calculated the speed of light
with clock work and mirrors.
- Okay, there we go.
Next. (bell rings)
- There we go.
This is Juliek from NB says, or fromed,
says, if you had unlimited
resources and time,
what would you build?
- Ooh.
- Oh, I'd build a spaceship
and I'd go to the moon
and then I'd go to Mars.
With unlimited resources
and material, yeah, totally.
I would start some
interplanetary exploration.
- Beautiful, love it.
In this office, I love that answer.
- [Chuck] All right, last question?
That's it?
- No, no, I don't think we have time.
Just final reflection.
Chuck, give me your final reflection.
- I am going to now pursue my weird urges.
- Weird urges.
- And I am really happy--
(overlapping dialogue)
- Go for it.
- I'm happy I have permission to do so.
- [Neil] Okay. Adam?
You got this book, presumably
there's still stuff in you
that's not in this book
otherwise buy the book
and then we don't have
to ever watch you again, right?
- Oh yeah, I held some stuff back.
- Tell me something that's not in the book
that we should carry with us.
- Oh wow.
That all human beings really wanna do
is tell each other stories.
And that's both science and art.
It's how we understand the universe.
- Even if the story you're telling
is how to build something.
- Indeed.
- Ooh, I like it.
Very nice.
- So what I'd like to think if I can add
to an earlier question about creativity,
to have a thought,
to see what everyone else has seen
and think what no one else has thought,
that's a commonly invoked
definition of genius.
But maybe it's not genius
that we're honoring there.
Maybe it's hard work,
where you have a lot of
dangling thoughts within you
because you've read a lot of books.
You've seen a lot of movies,
you've spoken to a lot of people.
You've done a lot of tinkering.
And they're sitting there
waiting in your head,
and then you walk amid all
of these dangling parts
and you say, give me two bits of that
and one part of that, one part of this
because they're available
to you to draw from
and out of that comes a brand new idea,
a brand new object, a brand new concept.
So I think the people who are cited
as the great inventors
and geniuses of the world
are simply those who
have more bits and pieces
in their lives waiting to be
assembled into something new.
- Hmmm.
- I totally agree.
- Very nice.
- It's beautiful that you agreed.
Because I pulled that from
the cosmic perspective.
(chuckles)
Adam, thanks for being on StarTalk.
Chuck, as always.
- Always a pleasure.
- You're my man, dude.
- Adam?
- A pleasure, gentlemen.
- You've been listening
to, possibly even watching,
this episode of StarTalk
featuring Adam Savage,
formerly of MythBusters.
And now he's just making stuff
and he's got us a Science Channel program
that I can't wait to catch.
Give me the name of it again?
- Savage Builds.
- Nice, sounds angry.
(laughter)
- June 12, June 12--
(overlapping dialogue)
- Summer 2019 on the Science Channel.
(laughter)
I've been your host, Neil deGrasse Tyson.
And as always, I bid
you to keep looking up.
- [Presenter] This
episode is brought to you
by CuriosityStream, a
subscription streaming service
made for viewers with inquiring minds,
including StarTalk fans just like you.
Get access starting at $2.99 a month.
Let me tell you about CuriosityStream's
How to Build series.
If you're a person that's a maker
and you wanna step up your garage game,
well, this is the show for you.
It gives you unprecedented access
to some of the world's
most advanced engineers
who are responsible for
satellites, supercars,
and the wings of jumbo jets.
Their Satellites episode is really cool.
They talk about how to build a machine
that will live for over a decade in space.
And of course, how it will deal
with the harshness of
the environment of space
and the suspense about
getting it into orbit.
Go to CuriosityStream.com/StarTalk
for unlimited access to the
world's top documentaries
and nonfiction series.
And for our listeners, enter
the promo code STARTALK
when you're prompted
during the signup process
and your membership is completely free
for the first 31 days.